70 jahre julia auf dem thron 96 jahre
leben es gab viele momente fröhliche
momente sehr traurige momente im leben
der queen blicken wir gemeinsam auf die
zehn wichtigsten momente im leben von
queen elizabeth der zweite
am 21 april 1947 absolviert die queen
damals noch prinzessin ihren ersten
großen internationalen auftritt bei
einem staatsbesuch in südafrika es ist
ihr 21
geburtstag dort hält sie eine
rundfunkansprache in der sie sich zum
dienst am kanal verpflichtet die rede
ist wegweisend für ihre zeit als königin
wenige monate später am 20 november
1947 läuten die hochzeitsglocken in der
westminster abbey in london die
prinzessin und der marineoffizier
philipp geben sich das jawort es ist die
erste adelshochzeit überhaupt die im
fernsehen übertragen wird etwa ein jahr
später am 14 november 1948 kommt ihr
erstes kind charts zur welt die königin
gilt als strenge mutter zweiter juni
1953 ein junges mädchen erklimmt den
thron ein jahr nach dem plötzlichen tod
ihres vaters wird elisabeth zur königin
gekrönt das jahrhundertereignis in der
westminster abbey sehen 300 millionen
zuschauer live im fernsehen die
zweistündige prozession durch london
wird zu einem spektakel mai 1970 erstes
bad in der menge
während eines staatsbesuches in
australien entscheidet der palast die
monarchen muss mehr volksnähe
daraufhin läuft sie durch die
begeisterten menschenmenge diese
walkabouts werden ein wichtiger und
fester bestandteil hunderter termine in
den nachfolgenden jahrzehnten
1992 das horrorjahr charts und trainer
trennen sich andrew und fergie auf
schloss windsor brennt fast up n lässt
sich von ehemann kapitän mark phillips
scheiben in ihrer weihnachtsansprache
sagt die queen
1992 seien es
zehn jahre später feiert die queen das
goldenen thronjubiläum es ist der 24
sechster 2002 eine million menschen auf
den straßen londons abends großes
popkonzert vor dem buckingham palast und
queen bassist brian may klettert auf das
palast ab um von dort god save the queen
zu spielen
22 juli 2013 london die geburt von
prince george macht die queen zur
urgroßmutter
erstmals in der geschichte der
britischen monarchie leben vier
monarchen zur selben zeit elisabeth die
zweite prinz charles prinz william und
prinz george der kleine george nennt die
queen nennen der zehnte april 2021 ist
ein schwarzer tag für die queen nach
mehr als 70 glücklichen ehejahren stirbt
der mann der queen friedlich auf schloss
windsor
philipp wurde 99 jahre alt während der
trauerfeier wirkt die queen
gedankenverloren und einsam die bilder
bewegen die welt juni
2022 die queen feiert 70 jähriges
thronjubiläum
vier tage lang dauern die
feierlichkeiten
zehntausende menschen ehren die
monarchen
[Musik]